did nebulous forgetfulness inadvertently
lead to the shocking death of a founding
Avenger or was it due to something even
more sinister
in the first Guardians of the Galaxy
film yandu is viewed as an adversary of
Peter a figure from his past with a lot
of baggage who poses a threat to him in
the present toward the end of Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol 2 Peter sees the ways
that yondu was something of a surrogate
father and understands how yandu may
have masked his true affection by
projecting aggression instead most of
all Peter discovers that yondu was hired
to retrieve Peter from Earth and deliver
him to Ego Peter's dad but chose to keep
Peter upon learning of ego's maniacal
true nature
this being said during his childhood
yondu frequently exploits Peter as a key
player in the ravager's heists to crawl
through spaces the adults couldn't fit
through to achieve their thievery that's
not great still when the alternative is
handing the boy over to a known killer
does the bad choice suddenly become an
Act of Goodwill maybe he just shouldn't
have kidnapped Peter to begin with
similar to how Peter Spence's youth
under the tutelage of a villain so do
Gamora and nebula though their father
figure is decidedly more nefarious than
yondu it's not until they're older that
they process their trauma as the adopted
Daughters of Thanos and redirect their
energy toward defeating it Gamora and
nebula are hardly to blame for their
actions at such a young age still
gamora's reputation and association with
Thanos precedes her when she winds up in
prison at the start of the first
Guardians of the Galaxy pretty high and
mighty coming from the lack of a
genocidal Maniac yeah I know who you are
Drax initially views her as partially
responsible for the death of his wife
and child who were killed by Ronan
another accomplice of Thanos it's this
dark past that Gamora strives to make
good upon as she seats a more heroic
life and so too does nebula eventually
Gamora and nebula grow up together as
Daughters of Thanos and their father
makes a deranged habit of pitting the
sisters against one another nebula
explains in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
2 that whenever she would lose Thanos
would replace part of her with Machinery
turning her into a cyborg but despite
this horror Gamora never let up when the
sisters eventually restore their
relationship Gamora apologizes telling
nebula I was a child like you
I was concerned with Staying Alive until
the next day every day and I never
consider what Thanos was doing to you
both of their Redemption arcs speak to
an ongoing theme within the Guardians of
the Galaxy films of growing into one's
full self as time goes on Gamora and
nebula both recognize that who they were
raised to be is not the person they
still want to be known as and take it
upon themselves to steer their light in
a different direction
as Peter Gamora Drax Rocket and Groot
team up for the first time in an attempt
to escape prison rocket lists a few
items he needs each of them to retrieve
in order for his plan to work a guard's
security band a special battery on the
wall and the prosthetic leg belonging to
one of their fellow prisoners you need
my what but as the others risk their
lives to procure these items we
discovered that rocket didn't need the
leg at all it was just a cruel prank I
thought it'd be funny wasn't funny but
wait what did he look like hopping
around Peter is rightfully ticked off
especially since he says he had to
transfer the prisoner thirty thousand
units to persuade him to give him the
way and besides the fact that a man who
is actually in need of a prosthetic limb
now has to do without it the timing of
the prank seems even more terrible given
the serious goal the group is trying to
accomplish was all of that really worth
a laugh to Rocket
there's a reason he's called Drax the
Destroyer in his Vengeance following the
death of his wife and daughter Drax goes
on a killing Rampage his targets Ronan
and ronan's boss Thanos in route to them
though he's not afraid to destroy anyone
and everyone remotely connected to his
family's loss in the first Guardians of
the Galaxy movie Ronan is still at large
and in search of the Power Stone which
happens to be in The guardian's
Possession knowing this Drax stupidly
lures Ronin to Nowhere the planet where
the Guardians have plans to trade the
Power Stone to The Collector drax's call
sets into motion a battle that could
have been avoided and leads to dire
consequences Gamora nearly dies and she
and Peter are abducted by the ravagers
plus Ronan gets the infinity stone and
nearly destroys a planet with it
everything turns out alright in the end
but drax's call to Ronan is
short-sighted and could have led to a
very different outcome
in the opening sequence of Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 2 The Sovereign hires the
Guardians to Vanquish a gigantic monster
the Guardians complete the job and seem
to be on good terms with Aisha until she
realizes that rocket stole a supply of
the sovereign's batteries this nullifies
the guardian's professional reputation
and sets into motion the sovereign's
quest to destroy the Guardians the
batteries eventually have a clever
callback when the Guardians use them to
implode the core of ego's Planet which
is the only viable solution to defeating
ego for good that does nothing though to
erase Aisha's hatred of the Guardians in
a mid-credits scene Aisha awakens a new
creation she calls Adam who is poised to
be a key player in 2023's Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol 3. anything consequential
that happens to the Guardians as a
result of Adam traces back to Rocket
cheating on their business deal
Baby Groot doesn't understand directions
very well in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol
2 the ravagers Mutiny against yondu and
lock up their former Captain along with
rockets Groot free to roam around the
ship but very absent-minded is the only
chance yandu and Rocket have of escaping
they need him to retrieve yondu spin
from his desk which will allow yandyu to
control his Flying Arrow explaining the
task to Groot is easier said than done
after many attempts to retrieve the Finn
Groot brings back several items that
have nothing to do with what he's
supposed to find one such item is a tow
a severed toe tell me you guys have a
refrigerator somewhere with a bunch of
seven human toes
okay then let's just agree to never
discuss this craglin ultimately comes to
their rescue turning on the crew and
choosing to remain loyal to yondu as his
captain but not before the audience sees
one of the darkest things baby Groot
ever does following the Mutiny against
yondu is the ravager's captain yondu
escapes from the crew's imprisonment
with rocket Groot and Cracklin everyone
who betrayed yondu is in for it using a
special Arrow commanded by a combination
of his Finn and whistling yondu kills
every crew member on the entire ship who
participated in his Mutiny meaning every
person who isn't himself rocket Groot or
craglin the arrow Zips and zooms
throughout the ship its speed fast
enough to pierce each of its victims
flesh and keep going coming out of their
back and continuing on to another crew
member even Baby Groot gets in on the
action extending his tiny arms into full
branches and fatally throwing someone
over the side of a rail ultimately the
death count has to be among the highest
we actually see any of the Guardians
commit on screen
despite their flaws the Guardians are
almost always likable there's one moment
though that pushes the audience's limits
of how much they're willing to forgive
in Avengers Infinity War members of the
Guardians of the Galaxy team up with a
handful of Avengers for the very first
time working together to remove The
Infinity Gauntlet from thanos's hand
they almost succeed before things take a
turn upon realizing Thanos killed Gamora
Star-Lord loses his cool attacking
Thanos before Iron Man and Spider-Man
have finished removing The Infinity
Gauntlet Star-Lord unravels the whole
plan Thanos regains his strength and
takes Back The Gauntlet ultimately
succeeding and retrieving the time Stone
from Doctor Strange and eliminating half
of all life in the universe it's a
heartbreaking moment on multiple levels
it it's difficult to put all the blame
on Star-Lord as he's just learned that
someone he loved is no longer alive at
the same time if Star-Lord could have
maintained his composure for just a few
more moments he might have been able to
kill Thanos himself and save the
universe in the process of course we see
an Avengers end game that star-lord's
mistake was part of the one way Doctor
Strange insists is the only path to
Thanos losing suggesting that perhaps
there is no reality where Star-Lord
doesn't screw things up in Avengers
Infinity War Thanos kills Gamora on
vormir as a sacrifice to retrieve the
Soul Stone nebula learns this
information later on in the film along
with other members of the Guardians of
the Galaxy the characters are certainly
aware that Thanos killed Gamora on
Boromir but do they know the
circumstances under which her death
happened he took her to warm here
he came back with
the something she did
the answer to this question is important
when you consider what follows in
Avengers end game as nebula Iron Man and
the other remaining Avengers put
together their Time Heist to go back in
time and retrieve the Infinity Stones
for themselves part of the plan involves
Hawkeye and black widow heading to
vormir to get the Soul Stone nebula
tells the rest of the Avengers that
vormir is where Gamora died do they put
two and two together do they realize the
toll the stone demands for as smart as
Tony Stark and the other genius Avengers
are and as intricate as the master plan
is for the Time Heist it seems unlikely
that nobody would have figured it out
it's just as unlikely though that the
Avengers would know this information and
not tell Hawkeye and black widow who
seemed surprised to discover the
sacrifice requirement upon arriving on
vormir given that nebula also forgets to
tell anyone that Thanos and her past
self are looking for the stone on Morag
though it seems like this could be a
pretty major oversight on her part
during the time heist in Avengers end
game a version of nebula from 2014
replaces the nebula that the Avengers
know in 2023 this brings 2014 Thanos
forward in time to finish what he
started as 2014 nebula is still very
much a villain having not yet evolved
toward the good guy's Side by disguising
herself as her future self she fools The
Avengers and nearly ruins everything
just after the team succeeds in
reversing the snap bringing back
everyone who vanished five years prior
2014 Thanos arrives uh-oh with the aid
of the resurrected heroes the Avengers
are able to defeat Thanos along the way
2023 nebula returns to her time and
kills 2014 nebula her former self
jeopardized the fate of the entire
universe by giving Thanos a second
chance to succeed big yikes
as a Christmas present for Peter in the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
mantis and Drax abduct Kevin Bacon from
Earth Peter's always talking about how
Kevin Bacon is an amazing hero and they
know he'll be thrilled with receiving
the actor as a gift only mantis and Drax
don't know Kevin Bacon is an actor they
believe him to be nothing short of the
ruler of the entire planet
no matter what profession or position Mr
bacon holds though Peter is not happy to
receive his gift and is quick to point
out that mantis and Drax have
effectively engaged in human trafficking
he's not even aware of the property
damage mantis and Drax caused at Bacon's
home or the police officers they
attacked in attempting their kidnap
what's more they've entranced bacon to
be amicable with his abduction mantis
breaks the trance at Peter's insistence
and bacon is understandably distraught
craglin begins to take him home but upon
learning the Footloose inspired Peter to
save the Galaxy bacon decides to stay
and help the Guardians throw a Christmas
party it's quite the turnaround for
someone who was violently abducted from
their home against their will love you
guys we love
all right
[Music]